[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chacun de vous qui êtes assis ici
aujourd'hui à des supers
il faut que je vous dise public
qu'il y a quelques années j'ai découvert
un secret à ce sujet
et ce secret il a changé ma vie donc je
suis heureuse de pouvoir vous le
partager aujourd'hui
je vous emmène avec moi je vous proposer
de quitter l'univers du tout mental et
ce besoin un petit peu irrépressible
qu'on a à l'heure actuelle de vouloir
tout analyser définir
anticiper finalement percevoir
intellectuellement et tout contrôler
j'ai commencé par vous raconter une
histoire
cette histoire c'est la mienne c'est mon
histoire mais c'est aussi un peu la
vôtre parce qu'elle nous parle de
quelque chose qui nous relie
profondément à la nature
et à notre véritable nature humaine
alors peut-être que on a un petit peu
oublié en cours de route
et nous sommes avant tout des êtres
sensibles
sensorielles et il n'y a pas nous et
notre environnement la nature
mais nous sommes la nature
n'est-ce pas
par exemple comme ça là le disait
moi je suis une fée sensible de la
nature
je vous assure
alors autant vous dire que d'être ici
face à vous
et bien c'est un joli défi
je vous rassure tout de suite malgré
tout même c'est gentil de m'encourager
quand je vous dis que je suis une
personne sensible je ne vais pas
m'effondrer en larmes ici sur cette
scène même ça dépend quand même un petit
peu de réaction
et je ne vais pas non plus vous raconter
l'histoire sucrée d'un monde merveilleux
fait de bisounours de licornes
un truc un peu perché c'est comme ça
qu'on dit
et en même temps ce que je me dis c'est
que ça nous ferait peut-être le plus
grand bien à tous
de revenir à cet état il y a ce regard
de l'enfance
vous savez celui où tout se vit en
connexion avec son cœur
avec les sens et avec cette évidence
cheville au corps
qu'il n'y a rien à comprendre
mais qui a juste à vivre l'instant
et elle ressentir
et justement pour moi vous savez tous
c'est vraiment jouer là lors de mon
enfant tout vient de ses racines là
c'est racines je les dois à une terre il
y a une culture qui m'ont tout offert
tout a pris
j'ai grandi pendant 17 ans en Afrique
alors mes parents se sont séparés
j'étais toute petite donc j'ai vécu
celle avec ma maman là-bas elle
travaillait beaucoup
donc j'ai eu cette chance de grandir
très libre en contact avec la nature et
enfin nourrir mes sens ma sensibilité et
aussi un imaginaire débordant
j'ai tout de suite su que j'étais faite
pour prendre soin
prendre soin de la nature de la terre
des autres et j'étais souvent
à vouloir défendre toutes les injustices
et je me souviens d'ailleurs
quand classe de CM2 monsieur Perret
notre instituteur nous avait diffusé un
reportage de Thalassa sur la mer d'Aral
qui à l'époque ça séchait déjà
et j'étais restée pendant toute la
récréation pour écrire combien ça
m'avait touché
j'étais mais emporté par cette histoire
et ma rédaction elle a fait le tour de
l'école et on m'a demandé à moi la
petite fille timide de venir la lire
devant tout le monde
et quand c'était comme ça quand je me
sentais touchée et bien j'étais capable
d'affronter toutes mes peurs et de
mobiliser des ressources insoupçonnées
je sentais qu'il fallait porter cette
voix
et d'ailleurs
je me demande si c'est pas un peu cette
petite fille
qui est là
aujourd'hui
debout devant vous
et en même temps ça aurait pu être
autrement
parce qu'elle a failli disparaître cette
petite fille
à l'âge de 17 ans je rentre en France
pour faire la connaissance d'un papa que
je connais peu et pour faire mes études
j'intègre alors un
schéma de ville moins de tout ce que je
connais loin de la nature loin de tout
ce qui m'a permis jusqu'ici de trouver
mon équilibre
et sans mes repères et bien je perds
totalement contact avec cette petite
Alexia à l'intérieur de moi
je m'oublie
je me sens perdue donc je choisis des
études et une voix professionnelle par
défaut et aussi pour répondre un petit
peu aux attentes de ce qu'on attend de
moi
je rentre dans le moule
je deviens délégué médical dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique
j'ai une bonne situation
je gagne de l'argent j'ai une voiture de
fonction des primes je pars en séminaire
à l'étranger
j'invite les médecins pour des réunions
scientifiques dans des lieux toujours
plus luxueux les uns que les autres
et je joue vraiment le jeu de cette vie
dictée par des exigences et des
croyances qui ne sont pas les miennes
et vraiment je sens que je ne passe pas
à ma place
mais ce qui est le plus fou c'est que je
mobilise une énergie de dingue pour
m'adapter à mon environnement
et je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
remarqué mais justement quand on observe
au printemps la floraison des arbres
donc en ce moment
et bien ce sont souvent les sujets les
plus mal en point
qui mettent le plus d'ardeur à fleurir
peut-être avez-vous vous aussi déjà eu
cette sensation de sur-adaptation au
monde qui nous entoure
c'est vraiment épuisant
alors pour
compenser ce mal-être je tombe dans le
piège de la consommation
un peu comme pour combler un vide
et je comprends très vite que plus on
accumule du matériel plus ça nous
éloigne de nous-mêmes
je me dis alors que si ce n'est pas dans
ma vie professionnelle que je trouve des
solutions ce sera peut-être dans ma vie
personnelle
j'ai toujours rêvé d'une famille unie
moi qui en ai manqué petite
je rencontre celui qui deviendra mon
mari et le père de notre fils
et notre couple est vraiment perçue par
tout le monde comme parfait
ce qui était vrai
il peu à peu au fil des années il y a
des complications importantes qui sont
apparus
et là je décide d'adopter le rôle de la
sauveuse
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
connaissent aussi ce rôle là c'est le
rôle en fait où on est animé de plein de
bons sentiments
vraiment
et on est persuadé qu'on est la seule
personne à détenir toutes les clés de la
situation
verdict
plus on s'acharne à vouloir aider plus
cela précipite les choses dans une
situation de non-retour
et là tout a volé en éclats
andré avait trois ans
décident de divorcer
et tous ceux en quoi j'ai cru
du plus profond de mon cœur s'écroule
ma famille c'était vraiment ce que je
voulais le réussir le plus
au monde
et vous souvenez tout à l'heure je vous
ai parlé de
cette petite fille
qui avait
failli disparaître
je voulais parler de d'une forme de mort
intérieur
et finalement c'est au moment où tout a
basculé que tout a pris un tournant
inattendu
les moments que je passais dans la
nature avec mon fils pour me
reconstruire me faisait le plus grand
bien
je me sentais mais émerveillée par tout
ce qui m'entourait j'en sentais
tellement puissante tellement d'évidence
dans ce lien à la nature
et dans ce qu'elle m'apporte parce
qu'elle nous apporte tout en fait
l'air qu'on est en train de respirer
ensemble à cet instant
l'eau que l'on boit
les nutriments des aliments qui nous
nourrissent
et puis simplement le fait d'être et
d'appartenir à scène à cette chaîne
incroyable du vivant
cette reconnexion elle agit sur moi
comme une renaissance à partir de ce
jour-là j'ai pris chaque jour le temps
de nourrir tout ce qui m'animait et ce
qui me permettait de garder contact avec
cette part de moi ou je sentais qu'elle
savait déjà tout
ça ça a été mon premier déclic
le deuxième
il s'est passé lors d'une formation
d'éducation à l'environnement sur les
approches sensibles
lors de cette formation j'ai vraiment
compris pourquoi la nature avait le
pouvoir de réveiller nos capacités
capacitaires incroyables de perception
endormie par nos modes de vie
la nature en fait elle a vraiment le
pouvoir de nous faire vivre une
expérience corporelle qui va réactiver
nos sens et notre sensibilité
lors de cette formation je suis avec des
profils de personnes très différents
et je me souviendrai toute ma vie
d'Odile
Odile c'est une femme de la cinquantaine
qui a un poste important pour une
collectivité territoriale
où il est sérieuse vraiment très
sérieuse
tout en elle me semble et guider par sa
part mentale et rationnelle
et il lors d'un jour de formation
pratique où on s'est retrouvé en pleine
nature
où on devait expérimenter les affranches
imaginaires on était amenés à vivre un
grand jeu de rôle on est tous devenus
des animaux de la forêt pour pouvoir
cohabiter et participer au conseil de la
forêt nous avait remis une petite fiche
qui précisait toutes les conditions de
vie de notre espèce donc il y avait
habitat réseau d'entre elles nourriture
prédateurs et donc on était en pleine
narration à fond et là tout d'un coup
j'entends Odile crier et rire à tue-tête
je lève les yeux vers elle et là je vois
son visage métamorphosé
elle exultait elle semblait être devenue
cette petite fille libre et joyeuse qui
sommeillait en elle
et là l'évidence
elle était là
la nature a vraiment ce pouvoir de nous
faire vivre
quelque chose qui nous ouvre à une autre
perception et réalité du monde
donc j'ai décidé d'en faire mon métier
c'est là que je suis devenue
entrepreneur du changement et qu'inspire
nature est née et où je propose
aujourd'hui
aux structures aux entreprises et aux
personnes d'intégrer davantage la nature
dans leur vie
ça fait 10 ans aujourd'hui
que j'ai décidé de changer de vie
et je vous parlais d'un secret tout à
l'heure
à mon secret c'est qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de grand chose
pas besoin de nouvelles technologies pas
besoin de process pas besoin d'artifice
de nos contraires
s'agit de revenir à quelque chose de
très simple
comme redonner du sens
à notre présence au monde
comme faire grandir notre intelligence
sensible et émotionnelle
comme prendre le temps
prendre le temps
d'observer d'écouter
de sentir
prendre le temps de simplement poser son
attention
prendre le temps d'aimer
c'est peut-être ça
nos super pouvoirs
et la nature elle elle a le pouvoir de
nous permettre de revenir à cette vraie
nature
ce que je vous dis là à cet instant je
sais que vous le savez déjà parce que
c'est toujours quelque part à
l'intérieur de nous
sauf que si j'ai décidé de venir
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est pour qu'on
s'en souvienne ensemble
alors je vous propose qu'on en fasse
l'expérience
venez avec moi
je vous emmène dans cette forêt
je propose tout d'abord de décroiser vos
jambes
c'est le moment interactif
et de prendre le temps ici de poser vos
plantes de pieds et bien au contact avec
le sol
que même assis
puissiez ressentir votre ancrage
avec la terre
vérifiez également que vos épaules sont
basses
que vos mâchoires sont desserrées
ça voudrait dire que vous êtes détendu
et c'est très bon signe pour notre
voyage
[Musique]
je vous propose avec les yeux ouverts ou
fermés comme vous le ressentez
de venir ici ensemble cousez notre
attention sur ce qui fait que nous
sommes tous ici et maintenant là à cet
instant
notre respiration
notre souffle
ce va-et-vient très fin de l'air
cette air frais
qui rentre par votre nez
et cet air plus chaud qui va ressortir
par vos narines votre bouche
pour laisser s'en aller
tout ce dont vous n'avez plus besoin
en inspirant
peut-être que vous sentez les odeurs de
la forêt
celles que vous aimez
l'odeur
fraîche et verte
des aiguilles des grands pins maritimes
peut-être une odeur plus boisée
d'une forêt de grands chênes
ou encore la douceur de l'odeur d'un
sous-bois de la terre
inspiré
inspirez profondément pour vous remplir
de toutes ces odeurs
et aussi vous laisser bercer par les
sons
les sons de la forêt
le bruit du vent dans les branches
le chant des oiseaux
peut-être loin vous entendez le bruit de
l'eau
les craquements du bois
le bruit de chacun de vos pas sur la
terre
laissez-vous envahir par toutes les
sensations
les émotions
que la nature peut provoquer en vous
imprégnez-vous de toutes les formes
toutes les couleurs
et ressentez combien dans cette forêt
il n'y a rien à faire il y a juste
à être
on vient
il n'y a rien à comprendre
mais il y a juste à ressentir
combien
il n'y a rien à dire mais il y a juste
à écouter encore
combien il n'y a rien à prouver
[Musique]
mais il y a juste à aimer
inspirez
[Musique]
pendant le temps
continuer à inspirer et respirer
profondément
tout doucement si vous aviez fermé vos
yeux pour les réouvrir
alors
du tout
mental
dans un monde où nous brillons par nos
prouesses intellectuels
alors qu'il est de plus en plus
incertain
inégal anxiogène
à l'heure du tout digital
dans un quotidien trépidant on s'épuise
à vouloir toujours plus
alors que tout est déjà là
à l'heure du changement climatique dans
une réalité notre impact sur le vivant
ne fait que croître
en ce jour
j'en ai de la terre
pensez-vous que nous puissions ensemble
offrir une autre empreinte à notre monde
pensez-vous
que nous avons en nous des supers
pouvoirs pour le réenchanter
[Applaudissements]